what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch from friend ryan airy
screen crushes spider-man 4 how venom
and hop goblin can enter the mcu what's
after no way home he poses the question
screen crush is constantly killing it
and despite the fact that ryanairy hates
john john you're gonna kill it on the
edit of this reaction video today okay
it's all for you ryan all for you
ryan
i'll text you this video after
yeah no pressure
welcome to screen crush i'm ryan airy no
way home paved the way for a perfect new
chapter for spider-man the old web head
is back to basics no iron man tech no
high advanced suits he's in the exact
place that spider-man needs to be he's
once again just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man swinging around the streets
of new york wearing his classic suit i'd
rather just stay on the ground friendly
neighborhood spider-man
somebody's got to look out for the
little guy right so spider-man 4 has a
lot of potential and we are so excited
that we want to share with you some of
our ideas plots characters and themes
that we hope to see in the next
spider-man film first spider-man 4
homeless whatever it's called
slinger back to dealing with street
level criminals as spidey goes against a
crime empire but things are not so easy
for spidey no one knows who peter parker
is it's like he never existed spider-man
4 needs to address the tragic events of
no way home and their impact on peter's
psyche which makes it the perfect time
for peter to bond with a certain exactly
the dark side that we hope to see is in
spider-man 4. sony i hope you're
watching because i have come to bargain
who am i
i'm spider-man as much as it seems like
it's obviously set up for peter to
finally bond with the symbiote as peter
is in one of the darkest points of his
life would being uh you know completely
alone at the same time though part of
the bonding with the symbiote what i
like most when it is interpreted in
comics or shows whatever is when you see
how it's affecting the relationships
around him and he currently as this is
set up doesn't have any relationships
yeah
you know so i think that's the one tiny
bit of apprehension i have towards it
but you never know i might have like
form new relationships or some people
might get their memories back et cetera
spider-man 4 needs to go back to basics
no more multiverse threats no more
living in iron man shadow spider-man
versus venom and maybe even spider-verse
will probably happen a few years down
the line but for spider-man 4 we need a
more personal story spider-man 4 needs
to deal with the consequences of no way
home focusing on spidey struggles in a
world where no one knows who peter
parker is so far the mcu spider-man has
always had someone to lean on from tony
to ned to may happy and of course mj but
now he's all alone broke and filled with
regret guilt and anger and uncertainty
does it depress you to know
just how sometimes i know
in a fascinating state of mind may is
dead because of his mistakes and just
when he finally got the chance to be
with mj he lost her possibly forever he
can never have the same relationship
with her or ned and i hope they wouldn't
just undo the memory wipe at least not
in spider-man 4. no way home was about
peter learning the terrible cost of
responsibility and the consequences of
his choices must stay intact for at
least a few movies i mean i don't know
if it has to be a few movies per se if
you think about even avengers infinity
war when everyone was dusted they only
had one more movie to do and then when
they all came back it was incredibly
awesome and cathartic because they knew
how to build to it in their follow-up
film and do it in an unexpected way so i
mean i feel like one movie of maybe not
everyone remembering him but at least mj
because as the script pointed out you
know there's a hint of like nostalgia or
reminiscent of exactly
yeah deja vu yeah yeah exactly before we
talk about the villains we want
spider-man 4 to focus on the criminal
element of new york especially now that
the year
is in the industry
i think you should be like the trilogy
villain don't leave eleanor other than
homecoming we never got a chance to see
spider-man deal with the criminal
underworld most of the other heroes are
busy with much bigger threats sort of
forgetting about the street-level crime
tony saw the vulture as a petty criminal
not a threat that he and the avengers
should waste their time on there are
people who handled this sort of thing
the avengers no no no just a little
below their hatred and this is how the
kingpin was able to build a criminal
empire right under the avengers noses
and this is why new york needs its
friendly neighborhood spider-man while
the other heroes deal with the big scale
threats spider-man is the one that can
help out the little guy i can see peter
committing himself to fully being
spider-man 24 7. when he's spider-man
he's at his best it's where he's most
confident
[Music]
but he needs to make a living that is
great
for me today
but after losing may peter is going to
shut himself out throw himself into
saving as many people as he can so no
one else dies on his watch being peter
parker is more of a mandatory chore for
him just something to do to get paid and
pay rent give me rent the movie also
needs to address peter's dark side as he
was close to crossing the line and
killing green goblin an interesting
direction will be if peter has more rage
in his heart now and that's something
that scares him because he was so close
to taking a life every criminal he
fights he sees norman osborn's face
hears his creepy laugh everywhere i go
i see his face
as he edges closer to doing something
that he's going to regret because of
this spider-man hesitates in every fight
he's too worried about losing control so
he keeps getting beaten up by the bad
guys and this is where venom comes in
don't lick things that don't want to be
licked it's only a matter of time till
the symbiote will bond with peter i mean
we need to get a proper spider-man movie
with the black suit this can't be the
only black suit spider-man in movie
history the black suit will give peter a
whole new edge that was great episode of
television right there but the sembians
will feed on peter's guilt doubts and
rage provoking him to be more brutal and
careless bringing him closer to taking
the lives of his enemies i told you i
give up that's funny i give up too i
give up trying to be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
so peter will have to face his darkness
both internally and physically as the
black suit will represent the
manifestation of peter's dark side the
world takes everything we love
there's no one you can trust peter
parker
no one except us
the clips you're pulling from for
spectacular spider-man i would love it
if they did do a visual representation
of that where you do go into the actual
mind you know especially with like
marvel cinematic universe they're phase
four or phase five minor on one of them
it seems like it's really shaping into
like the mind bending phase of the
marvel cinematic universe so to do
things that are a little bit more
psychedelic in that regard would be
really cool to actually behold and i
hope john watts does stay on board
because we gotta see him do a little bit
more of the darker side in spider-man no
way home so if he is able to do like the
symbiote bonding i think we'd be in good
hands at that point oh yeah and you
could create another sort of rhyme with
the previous spider-man like he brought
up the whole thing about like him seeing
norman osborne everywhere but if you had
you know the shadow side of himself kind
of always in a debate with the qualities
of peter i think that could be a cool
like how james franco sees norman like
how andrew garfield sees captain stacy
oh yeah we gotta have somebody's ghost
dad here ghost dads ghost dads so this
being said spider-man 4 cannot repeat
the same mistakes of spider-man 3. so
a no creepy dancing in the street
please please don't say that
no emo parker c don't just throw venom
into the final battle of the movie the
actual spider-man vs venom story needs
to happen at a later point either
spider-man 5 or a crossover movie for
the main villain there are two options
that i'm hoping for the fan favorite is
craven the hunter but we'll talk more
about him in a moment as much as i love
craven i think the most fitting villain
for spider-man 4 is the hobgoblin
oh
and that's great on time
because he would be ned
and then it would be a personal dilemma
for him okay oh that's all right all
right never mind i might always start
racing i'll just play your video right
i got really excited at that very
excited it's just suddenly clicking me
i'm like oh that's why you're tying them
together okay he is the most interesting
choice as a follow-up to the green
goblin exactly pop goblin is one of
spider-man's most popular villains
mostly thanks to the great hobgoblin
saga from the comics and the 90s
animated show while he looks like an
orange green goblin he's not crazy like
osbourne he's far more cunning and
devious he's more like a crime boss and
this ties into the criminal element of
spider-man 4. if peter is going to see
goblin's face everywhere it only makes
sense to have a villain who looks like
him and i'm sure they could just
entertain ptsd
osborne but it's too soon to have
another green goblin as the villain
after no way home sure the hobgoblin
that i want to see in the mcu is
roderick kingsley never mind he's not
doing what i thought leeds also became
hobgoblin at one point or maybe that was
retconned i can't remember and there
were a lot of teases and no way home
that ned was going to become a villain
but right now
i don't see ned as a villain oh time
will tell but the hobgoblin i hope to
see is a shrewd businessman who rules a
criminal empire me that would be cool he
already is a crime boss in new york and
that's kingpin now that they finally
brought him back it's a no-brainer that
will see him and spider-man clash and
this will also open the door to a team
up with spider-man and daredevil but
don't get mad but i'm not so sure it'll
happen let me explain not yet in the
spirit of the holidays i'm going to give
you a minute to think about what you're
starting right now daredevil is
confirmed for the echo disney plus show
where i assume that he will team up with
maya lopez against the kingpin assuming
that fisk is still alive
horses
don't you dare so fisk is tied to
daredevil and echo and i have a feeling
that kate bishop will be involved
somehow as well since she's also part of
the reason for his downfall this makes
spider-man kind of the third wheel here
and that's one of the issues with the
mcu spider-man trilogy all of the
villains had conflicts unrelated to
spider-man himself the vulture and
mysterio were essentially iron man
villains and all the baddies in no way
home were already established as the
previous spider-man's villains peter
needs an antagonist that has a personal
hatred toward him that's a great own
arch nemesis this is why the hobgoblin
fits so well i mean obviously we're
gonna want to hear what you gotta say
about your choice for the hop goblin but
i am on the side of like like i said
earlier with the symbiote or the
relationships especially if he knows the
identity of who the hop goblin is like
of course peter would be super
apprehensive about fighting someone like
him and if he is like the combination
effect of the reflection of green goblin
like this is his best friend
but the symbiote would make him see past
all that
so i think you would have something
that's a real personal villain that
would support this whole thing of it
being a villain that is just congruent
with peter parker himself
but you're smarter than me so i want to
hear you guys
so here's how i think things will play
out after season three of daredevil
wilson fisk's criminal empire falls
apart the show hawkeye pretty much
confirms that because fisk has been fist
downgraded from being the head of a
criminal empire to being the boss of the
tracksuit mafia keep bishop this guy bro
bishop is not guy okay bishop is going
costly wow
so fisk's downfall created a power
vacuum and roderick king's leak took
over i want hog goblin to be a crafty
villain someone who's capable of
creating his own weapons and tech
kingsley built a criminal empire ruling
the criminal underworld to cover his
tracks publicly he's playing the role of
a wealthy businessman someone who the
public loves using a bunch of patsies to
take the blame for his crimes he's elon
i was acting
or was i but now spider-man is sticking
his webs into his criminal empire and
kingsley takes it personally at first
he'll hire some villains to go after
spider-man someone like the scorpion
matt gargan was introduced briefly in
homecoming and he has his own vendetta
against spiderman two characters two
actors from better call saul
gargan is also breaking spiderman so
maybe he's the one who's going to bond
with the symbiote at the end of the
movie so scorpion will challenge
spider-man for a bit but once peter gets
the black suit he's going to take gargan
down kingsley will use his craftiness
and he'll piece together spider-man's
connection to the green goblin finding
out about the green goblin killing may
or spider-man almost killing the goblin
kingsley will create the hobgoblin
persona to mess with spider-man's mind
peter's rage will distract him giving
hobgoblin the upper hand against the
webhead maybe kingsley will hire black
cat to get close to spider-man and learn
about his secrets now can we talk like
human beings
this feels pretty human to me felicia
hardy is an incredible anti-hero and she
fits perfectly into spider-man 4. she
and spider-man have a pretty complicated
and spicy romance peter needs a new love
interest now they can't be with you yeah
that's a great call for a while now
shouldn't be gwen stacy i mean i prefer
to see her introduced at a later point
as spider-gwen black cat is someone
who's fresh both a lover a friend but
also at times spider-man's enemy and
this is a fresh take on spider-man's
usual romances and unlike peter's
agreement
she doesn't need any savings she can
kick ass just as well as him peter
decided to not reintroduce himself to mj
probably thinking that she's better off
without him because everyone close to
him gets hurt he's completely alone in
the world just like the black cat she
also lives a double life feeling more
alive as black cat than she does as
felicia both of them suffer terrible
traumas at a young age and lost loved
ones so she's the perfect match for
peter in his current state she might be
the only good casting choice
since black cat is far more morally
ambiguous than mj she will actually like
peter's personality in the black suit
well at least at first are we going to
be bad guys together partner
or just plain bad
was it something i said you know out of
everything you've pitched so far
this whole thing about black cat is
actually one of the best things i've
heard that's my favorite in terms of
theorizing what people can do and
speculating for the spider-man for this
romance which obviously is kind of
reflective of like a batman and catwoman
type of situation just knowing who black
cat is there could be more personal ties
like even in the spectacular spider-man
show you guys have had a few years to
watch so cover your ears if you haven't
heard this or haven't seen it but there
was an episode where it does unveil that
her father was the one who shot uncle
ben and i think having some personal tie
like that creating like a level of push
and pull between them i don't know if
you have to do that obviously like uncle
ben hasn't even established yet so point
being is that there's more to explore
with black cat as well and i like the
idea of him having like a a safer
romance in his heart like that kind of
like psychological effect of i can't
really be with her because she's also
kind of a criminal yeah yeah so keeping
her at a distance but there's sexual
chemistry yeah no i mean just listening
to this my mind started to run wild of
yeah all the different ways this could
enchant and entice peter but also
present sort of an interesting obstacle
on a very personal level and if she is
hired but that is a little too dark
night rises for my taste yeah
like you don't want it to be like i
almost fancy it just that he comes
across her one night out fighting crime
and then they develop this sort of you
know cat and mouse kind of thing and
then somehow that factors in but not
like uh she was hired directly to like
coming or something like that hobgoblin
would hire her to go after spider-man
using her skills to string him along
make him trust her and reveal his
secrets so this could be a somewhat
toxic romance between the two as both
the symbiote and black cat will be a
negative influence on peter but
eventually once black cat sees the true
darkness of the symbiote she will try to
help peter while also facing her own
inner darkness peter's struggle with his
inner darkness and the black suit is
likely going to cause him to reunite
with mj and ned
everybody needs help sometimes peter
even spider-man it's still unclear
exactly how the memory spell works but i
assume that mj and ned remembered that
they knew spider-man without knowing
peter now we got to talk about craving
the hunter i can make you a true hunter
not just a boy pretending to be a man
he's the fan favorite and one of
spider-man's best villains spider-man
must face craven at some point even if
it's not in spider-man 4. we need to get
an adaptation of craven's last hunt in
the marvel cinematic universe hobgoblin
could hire craven to go after spider-man
though i don't want the movie to be too
overcrowded with villains so it's best
to have them in separate movies there is
one caveat with craven and that's that
he's getting his own standalone movie so
far all the sony villain movies take
place in a separate universe from the
mcu also it's important to mention that
craven is one of the villains that was
teased in no way home and i think that
some of the others could appear in
spider-man 4. the main thing i want to
see with the villains in the new
spider-man trilogy is characters that
have not yet appeared in any previous
movies especially because we just saw
most of them in no way home also the
movie needs to explore how the people of
new york react to spider-man after the
events of no way home because much of
spider-man's story is about the people
of the city he protects
that's very true you want to get to him
you got to go through me
and me
me too remember everyone still believes
that he killed mysterio no way holm
explored some of the ramifications of
the public's opinion but it was put
aside in favor of the multiversal crisis
having the black suit will surely
complicate things as the symbiotes will
cause them to do some bad stuff and
spider-man's reputation will only get
worse so i hope spider-man 4 will deal
with peter having to regain the public's
trust as spider-man as he proves his
worth as a hero and new york's protector
that's why i want to see roderick
kingsley being this beloved public
figure he could use the public's trust
to turn them against spider-man even
more and in the end peter will expose
him show the world just how easy it is
to manipulate the public and the truth
this way people might start doubting
mysterio's lies this could lead to a
fascinating arc for peter okay so far
would you pitch with kingsley yeah that
does sound really great naturally
because you can have like the personal
dynamic with black cat obviously it
would be personal because of the the
rivalry or the the enemy versus
protagonist dynamic that would form
between them but yeah with having
someone who's like of criminal
enterprise to go directly up against
while kingpin is still being used for
like the echo series and slowly building
himself up i feel like kingpin should
still be featured in here
to be
become like the ultimate villain for
attend
like the sixth spider-man movie yeah for
sure but that would be a great way to do
it uh but in terms of doing this
scenario it will also explain the tech
yeah there's there's a lot to support it
oh yeah and i feel like introduce the i
mean i guess it'll go a little bit more
in terms of like was the other one demi
goblin yeah yeah if never to do
something because of his witcher bill
which craftability yeah yeah i mean i
i'm so torn because like you know that
the ned setups are there and and i feel
like that's something a lot of people
would like to see although i do really
like this idea of a new entity taking on
a character that is definitely going to
rattle peter but doesn't have like that
you know like i know you directly sure
even with the spell and all that like i
don't know i feel like that could
present a really interesting challenge
for peter but i could see it both ways
i'm very told yeah the movie needs to
show us that peter has a new role model
two to be exact so far peter's always
looked up to tony and the other avengers
using them as an example of the kind of
hero that he needs to be i just wanted
to be like you
and i wanted you to be better
but after meeting the other two
spider-men i want peter to use them as
an inspiration because they're just like
him friendly neighborhood spider-man but
at the same time finding new inspiration
not in anyone else but in himself that
will be the perfect culmination for
spider-man 4 and the new start for the
trilogy as peter finally learns to
appreciate himself and understand that
being peter parker and spider-man is
what makes him who he is one of the
greatest heroes in the mcu and this is
why i hope the fourth spider-man movie
will be titled the spectacular
spider-man
spectacular spider-man
let me know what you think of all this
what villains do you want to see in
spider-man 4 let me know in the comments
below or at me on twitter and if it's
your first time here please subscribe
and smash that bell for screen crush i'm
ryan airy
excellent job ryan yeah it's a great
pitch you can't argue with it that was a
terrific pitch this is a fantastic pitch
and i love the idea of calling it the
spectacular spider-man 2. god that
series needs to be revived what are you
doing disney plus
do it well you know we got to get his
high school show out of the way first
then maybe we can go back to spectacular
i want spectacular spider-man back such
a fantastic show and ended on such a
cliffhanger my god start a hashtag it's
they've had petitions and everything
already for a while keep them going
don't give up on the fight people it's
the faith all right guys subscribe to
screencast you haven't done so already
uh thanks ryanair for putting this
together
catch you guys soon
[Music]